all the years you were doing it there's
certain guests like who are the guys now
that you you're going to work your
memory bank like who would come on and
kill it and you go [ __ ] this is a great
show whether I get ratings or not oh
yeah this guest knows how to be a good
talk show guest there's so many times in
my life and you've seen this where
you understand
it's not an accident the time in Bruce
Springsteen we were fortunate enough to
have on our show a couple of times
and he would show up
early
he would rehearse
he learned he knew all the cameramen's
names he learned their names he was a
gentleman he he crafted it he figured it
out uh and you think oh this is he
doesn't need to prove anything on Late
Night with Conan O'Brien he's got
nothing to prove he's got nothing to
prove to anybody he's doing and then
he's hanging out afterwards and thanking
people you think there's this is not an
accident there's a reason he's Bruce
Springsteen and I feel that way about
Tom Hanks I feel that way about because
that is a guy who when I was at Saturday
Night Live and then again when I did my
all my late night shows over the years
he would show up early
he would have ideas he brought stuff to
the table when I was at SNL he would
stay up all night pret not the whole
night but he would stay up till like
four in the morning
and I remember walking through the
writer's room conference room once and
he was lying on the conference table at
like four in the morning and he was like
Conan what do we got what are you boys
cooking up like I got an idea and and
and you know he's a huge biggest movie
star in the world right you could see
that this is why he's Tom Hanks it's not
that he's Tom Hanks or they're Bruce
Springsteen and then they're trying to
be a good guy no they this work ethic
this it has to be good and I need to
show people my appreciation because
that's it's emotional intelligence
all right